yes
so when you do if you do material like
that do you find that because i would
imagine being on an adult swim you have
you know it's a network yeah so there's
people from
both sides for sure both sides right
yeah i mean yeah i uh getting it took a
lot of yeah take i take a lot of heat
for that stuff you do yeah and does that
i don't i don't know for this in the
case of
uh yeah we don't have to get too
political but the case of trump it just
felt like i mean vic too
oh yeah it was also his thing but it was
like you just couldn't stay quiet i
couldn't stay quiet about it he was like
but the difference between what you're
doing and what what
what tim is doing is you're out front
what i'm saying is if you're performing
live in a club and you start doing this
i would imagine
well yeah i the thing is i've never been
uh i've never like been a guy that like
would just be at a club i think like
where do you play where do you play well
with the band
uh i mean i would say like
how do you how do i describe how do i
explain this like it's a club it's a
theater i mean i just want a bar you
wouldn't book me at like a comedy club
in kalamazoo or something right a week
because where would your band play uh in
la we'd play it like the zebulon or
uh
i mean
i guess what i'm saying is
and with eric too like when we would
play the audience would be there to see
us they're not there to see
entertainment or
comedy or music they're they're
you know they're there to see us
they know the deal they're in on the
joke or they're
they're they're fake i guess the reason
i bring it so it's hard it's a little
hard to just say like oh i'm going to be
down at the irvine improv for a week and
whoever's there is going to appeal to
them it's not going to it's not going to
appeal to everybody right so i'm never
going to try to do that because you can
have a different life where you just go
on the road i mean a good example might
be like the band fish who i don't
necessarily like but they have an
audience that will do and go to see them
you know wherever whenever they're doing
their thing but you might not want to
book fish at the
fairgrounds for the week because people
might be like
annoyed with it you know you guys
perform live okay i would think though
that once you start opening up and
talking about whatever your political
views may be you garner
the audience that agrees with you
necessary so like if they're going to
see you it's probably the audience that
has the same point of view because
you've been open about it and you've
already it's not going to be a big
surprise right yeah yeah but i was going
to say like i mean trump is like you've
mocked him for years i mean i remember
the first time i saw you do stand up you
were you know mocking him or whatever
but like i mean like outside of politics
and policies he's a ridiculous
character in the world all i'm saying is
that now and maybe i'm more um
raw about it right and i don't know how
long after the event that happened at
the academy awards
you know this is this is actually airing
but you know
now
uh hitting hot points on stage is going
to mean so much more and i was
if anything
came out of personally for me at the
academy of wars was fear you know of
opening up this can of worms to an
audience that doesn't agree one and all
it takes is one person that doesn't
agree with what you're saying yes and
you know
up until now it was about being canceled
it was maybe about being disliked or not
booked
now you can get hurt so
you know
yeah i mean
luck i mean well vic and i have both
dealt with this where that sort of troll
mentality online
often feels very removed and very out in
the comments sections
but
there were points in our both of our
lives where it suddenly showed up at our
doorstep in very real ways really uh are
you okay to talk about it well just
nothing i mean nothing you know stuff
sent to our house and vic had a bigger
night or a visitor from the proud boys
come to my house and
tell me stop making fun of them and stop
making videos about them they found your
they found my address and the guy yeah
some
wacko drove from boston to pennsylvania
at the time to knock on my door
yeah we don't need to get that we don't
need to bring it down too loud no but
it's not bringing it down i think it's
kind of interesting yeah it's
interesting it is real there's articles
about it and stuff there's uh you know
you do make you do risk when you speak
publicly about how you feel about things
of course you risk opening yourself up
to people that disagree with you yeah
[Music]
you